البدايه مشاهدينا من تطورات حرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا حيث قالت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه انها تصدت لهجوم صاروخيا روسيا
استهدف العاصمه كييف تزامن هذا الهجوم مع
بدء وفد الوساطه الافريقي زيارته الى
اوكرانيا حيث يلتقي الرئيس
بينما اكدت موسكو افتاحها على بحث خيارات
لتسويه الازمه وقالت ان اقتراحات الوفد
الافريقي ستبحث خلال لقاء بوت مع القاده
الافارقه غدا الى كيف الان مباشره حيث
ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره عدنان بوريني
وايضا نرحب
مناسبه الجزيره رانيا دريدي ابدا معك
رانيا اذا من حديث بوتين كنا نستمع قبل
قليل في المنتدى
الاقتصادي الدولي الى مجموعه من الاشارات
حول النمو الاقتصادي وتجاوز
الحصار ربما تطرق الى نقاط اخرى حدثينا
عن ابرز ما جاء في كلمه بوتين
نعم محمد يعني بغض النظر عن الكم الهائل
من المواضيع الاقتصاديه التي تناولها
والتي وهنا لابد من الاشاره الى ان
المؤتمر لا يزال مستمرا ولكن هنا لابد من
الاشاره الى ان الملاك فالاوكراني كان هو
الاخر قد احتل جزءا هاما جدا في خطاب
بوتين لهذا العام تحدث بوتين عن جذور
الازمه الاوكرانيه والتي دفعت روسيا حسب
تعبيره لخوض العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
اشار الى ان الحرب حسب تعبيره على الارض
اوكرانيا كانت قد بدات قبل نحو تسعه اعوام
عام 2014 وذلك بدعم غربي حسب تعبيره وذلك
بعد رفض السلطات الاوكرانيه المدعومه من
قبل الغرب بتنفيذ اتفاقات ميسك المعنيه
بتسويه الاوضاع في جنوب شرق اوكرانيا في
منطقه دانباس وحسب تعبيره روسيا اضطرت لي
التدخل على وجه التحديد لانهاء هذه وليس
لبدايتها حسب تعبيره بشكل عام في الملف
الاوكراني يمكن القول ان الرئيس الروسي
لاديمير بوتين ركز على نقطتين اساسيتين
النقطه الاولى وهي مساله اجتثاث النازيه
التي تحدث عنها منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه على الارض في اوكرانيا اشار
بوتين في تصريحاته اليوم الا ان العديد من
وصفهم باصدقائه يعتبرون
الرئيسكي عارا على الشعب اليهودي اشار
بوتين الى ان فانديرا الذي يدعمه زيلينسكي
والذي يعتبره باطلا قوميا في اوكرانيا هذا
الشخص واتباعه قضوا خلال الحرب العالميه
الثانيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه فقط على
نحو مليون
وخمسمائهودي خلال الهولوكوست فضلا عن ذلك
النقطه الثانيه وهي ايضا تاتي في اطار
اهداف العمليه العسكريه الروسيه هي مساله
نزع السلاح الاوكراني في هذا الاطار اشار
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الى لان
روسيا ترى ان الغربي يسعى جاهدا
لتحقيق هزيمه استراتيجيه على الارض بروسيا
للحاق هذه بروسيا ولكنه شدد مره اخرى على
ان روسيا كانت قد وضعت هذه الاهداف فيما
يتعلق بنزعها السلاح الاوكراني وستقوم
بتحقيقها اشاره الرئيس الروسي الا ان
قريبا اوكرانيا
يعني ستبقى كل اسلحتها محليه الصنع وانا
حاليا تحارب على الارض بكل الاسلحه التي
تحصل عليها من الغرب وهذا الامر لن يدوم
الى ما لا نهايه الى وقت طويل حسب تعبيره
اذا هذه الجزئيه وجزئيه اخرى تحدثت فيها
بما يتعلق بالعمليه العسكريه على الارض
الذي اشار الى ان حتى هذه اللحظه في هجومه
المضاد فشل الجانب الاوكراني بتحقيق اي من
النجاحات على الارض مشير انه يتكبد خسائر
فادحه ليس فقط بالارواح وايضا بالمعدات
العسكريه لنتابع لابرز ما قاله بوتين خلال
هذا المؤتمر في الشان الاوكراني
الرجل نرى جيدا الجهود الغربيه لالحاق
هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا انهم يقومون بكل
شيء لتحقيق ذلك لكننا بدورنا وضعنا مهمه
محدده ازاء ذلك وهي نزع سلاح اوكرانيا
قريبا جدا ستستنفذ اوكرانيا جميع الاسلحه
التي صنعتها وستعتمد فقط على الدعم
العسكري الغربي والاسلحه الغربيه لكنها لن
تستطيع ان تحارب طويلا بالاعتماد على
السلاح الغربي اما نحن فاننا نتقدم في
صناعاتنا العسكريه لقد ازداد انتاجنا عشره
اضعاف
شكرا رانيا نشرك الان عدنان النابوريني من
كييف وكنا نتحدث عدنان حول وفد الوساطه
الافريقي
محمد بين لحظه واخرى ربما سنستمع الى
نتائج هذه الزياره من المرتقب ان يكون
هناك مؤتمر صحفي كما تحدثت الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه هنا للصحفيين في اوكرانيا يتم
الحديث عن مؤتمر صحفي سيشترك فيه الرئيس
الاوكراني بالاضافه الى من حضر في هذا
الوفد الافريقي نتحدث عن رئيس الجنوب
الافريقي الرئيس السنغالي رئيس الوزراء
المصري وايضا الرئيس زامبيا بالمبدا تقول
كياب انها تستمع وتنبسط لهذه المبادرات
لكن وفق معايير محدده تقول ان اساس اي
مبادره ينبغي ان يضع بالحسبان النقاط
العشره التي تحدث بها وقت سابق كمبادره
للسلام ولانهاء الحرب بشكل اساسي تقوم على
انسحاب القوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بشكل كامل هذه الزياره ما زالت
لم تنتهي حتى هذه اللحظه من المفترض ان
اللقاء تم لكن الحديث عن مؤتمر صحفي قريب
جدا ربما نراه خلال لحظات او خلال ساعه
على ابعد تقدير على ايه هذه الزياره قطعت
اليوم بحدف كبير قال وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني انها قطعت باكبر هجوم صاروخي
روسي منذ اسابيع نتحدث عن نحو 12 صاروخا
بالستيا بالاضافه الى مسيرتين سته صواريخ
كنجال وايضا سته صواريخ كاليبر تقول
القوات الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه ان ان قوات
تصدت بشكل كامل لهذه الصواريخ لكن لا ينفي
ذلك انه حطام احد الصواريخ سقط على بضعه
منازل ريفيه في خارج مدينه كييف لكن داخل
حدود المقاطعه نترقب حتى الان نتائج هذه
المبادره وهذا الطرح الافريقي كما قلنا
تقول كيب انها تستمع لكن وفق معايير محدده
ليس هناك الكثير متوقع من ذلك محمد
ميدانيا بشكل اساسي يتم الحديث من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه عن هجوم مضاد مستمر
يركز بشكل اساسي على الجبهه الشرقيه يتم
الحديث عن تقدم على اكثر من جبهه واكثر من
خط لكن بنفس الوقت يقول قائد القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه على
الرغم من هذا الهجوم الاوكراني ترسل مزيد
من التعزيزات العسكريه والمعدات تحديدا
الى كنا تحدثنا ونعيد محمد بخصوص خيرسون
هناك تطور مهم في مدينه خيرسون نتحدث عن
ما اعلنته نائبه وزير المتحدث عفوا باسم
العمليات في الجنوب بان القوات الروسيه
بدات العوده الى المناطق التي انسحبت منها
بعد الغمر الذي طال المنطقه هناك تفجير سد
كخوفكا هذه العوده ترشح المشهد في خرسون
لمزيد من التصعيد بشكل كبير وبدانا نستمع
الى اخبار منذ ساعتين تقريبا بدا الحديث
عن قصف هناك في خرسون طاله بعض المنازل
شكرا لك يا عدنان بوريني من كيف واشكر
رانيا ايضا من صمت شكرا جزيلا لكما